hi my name is
daniel mcdonald uh i am the lead
developer
for synthetic geometry at wolfram
research and along with my colleagues
uh peter and joffan uh we're gonna be
talking to you a bit about some of the
uh
new and upcoming features in
uh planar geometry in the wolfram
language
um i'll start
with uh a quick example um
this is taken from euclid's elements
uh and it is a
construction of
a regular um
triangle given uh
two of its vertices um
so new for 12 2 we will
uh geometric scene will support
geometric
step uh which allows uh
us to construct geometric scenes
one step at a time now these steps don't
necessarily have to be
uh uh straight edge and compass
uh classical geometric construction
steps
um but they certainly can represent them
so let's uh take a look
right so we've got
four steps here i start with two points
a and b
draw circles uh centered at each one
and going to the other uh drop the point
c
and uh in the intersection of both
circles and then
conclude that uh the triangle abc is
regular
right so if we run that we get uh we get
the scene
um uh we
start on the uh the final step but we
can uh
go through and see how
from the beginning and see how the the
scene was constructed
um if we want to uh modify our scene a
bit
for 12 2 um geometric scene
will uh will be dynamic so
uh for instance if i want to move a
around
um it'll move the point a and then
also make sure that the rest of the
scene
moves around to um
to make sure that the scene is still
valid
uh we can recenter and if we want to uh
draw move c to the other side and this
intersection
we can drop it close and uh and then
it'll figure out
um how to snap it to uh
to actually fit the scene so we said
that triangle
abc is regular and if you're uh
um you know follow euclid's logic then
you believe it
but uh if you happen to
not be able to read greek then
we can do do a check so
this geometric solve function will be in
the
wolfram function repository during
twelve two so this will
not be a system function yet uh but
uh here we can
use it on the scene and solve for the
euclidean distances between a b
b c and c a and hopefully
they should all be the same
and they are just a tad over four
if you are curious about
not about this particular
um scene but just
uh you know this particular instance of
the scene but rather
um the
kind of underlying algebraic formulation
behind the scene
uh we can show you that now
with this algebraic formulation sub
value that you can access from this menu
and it'll show um you know for these
points
you know a b and c um you know using
um a sub 1 for
for the x coordinate of a a sub 2 is the
y coordinate of a and so on
um we can spit out this kind of
algebraic formulation that describes
describes all of the uh points and
quantities
introduced in this scene and you'll
notice um
we also uh intro with we have an
existential quantifier with some
uh computer generated variables to
make the uh um
to make the formulation uh
a little bit smaller uh now i'm going to
hand
hand this presentation off to peter
who's going to
talk about some uh
automated proving functionality uh
before we hand it off to uh
zhao fan who will talk a little more
about euclid so thanks for listening to
me but
uh stay tuned hi i'm peter behrens i'm a
senior content developer in wolfram
alpha
and today i'll be talking about a new
function find geometric proof
which takes our new geometric scene
language
to create a readable synthetic proof
that can be understood by
9th grade geometry students or even
euclid himself
so to give a preliminary example
um we have a scene in our new scene
language
that describes basically a triangle but
we're only given
the altitude of three
and the area of 13 we have to specify
that
this angle is 90 degrees so that you
know it's the altitude
this is how the the scene drawer would
draw it
to use it to find the
base which is from y to z
we give the the pattern
that we want to find
in the first argument so here we say
including distance from y to z
equals something we want to find and
approve effect like that
and the second argument is the scene
which is the assumptions that we're
working with
so we run this and we get a proof object
something which already exists in the
language as an output of find equational
proof
there's many things you can do with this
proof object but the most important
thing
is the proof notebook which gives you
that
that nice two-column proof that you're
used to working in
i've get great geometry there's a lot of
properties
as well and here's a list of them the
first
four are really just accessing
some of the basic facts about the proof
object like what axioms were used what
was the logic in this case of the
synthetic geometry
what was the theorem we tried to prove
and what was the result
and various other methods of
showing the proof computably as a data
set and we'll go into some of these
other ones
and then proof notebook of course
so here's the what will be the usage
statement for find geometric proof
basically uh if it succeeds in finding a
proof of the theorem
or proof that the theorem results in a
contradiction
then it returns a proof object
expression if no proof
is found it'll return a failure object
but it will still contain useful
information
the options to find geometric proof
where the research resource function
will be as follows so there's the
obvious ones the time constraint you can
give
whether you want the angles to be in
degrees or radians
whether you want the the facts proved
to have a certain depth so you don't
want to prove
facts that were sort of too complicated
and not very interesting
and there's also a max iterations option
because what the prover does essentially
is it
iterates over the set of known facts to
that point
and then it uses a gigantic replace list
to try to apply
all these theorems which are really
replacement rules
and to generate new facts and finally we
have a geometric axioms
option which is still being worked on
but it will let you
change the background set of assumptions
to your euclidean geometry or
other things such as including
trigonometry
other kinds of facts
so in the second example let's consider
three points on a circle where
two of them are at the ends of the
diameter of the circle
and we're given one of the angles from
b a to c and we want to know
what else we could find in particular we
want to know the other angle
from a b uh one of the other angles from
a b to c
you may recognize this as thaley's
theorem so bailey's theorem says
that this angle is always 90 degrees and
it subtends the diameter
and indeed if we run
if we ask it to find what the the planar
angle is
and we want to insist that the answer is
numeric
otherwise it could give us just
something sort of silly like the planar
angle abc
is equal to some other planar angle
we see that we get a proof object in
four steps really just one step because
three steps are the givens
and that that final step the one
meaningful step really just
reiterates daily's theorem and says that
like they only stay on the the
angles the angle is 90.
now to demonstrate the geometric axioms
option
we can essentially um what i've done
here
collided is to is to delete
thaley's theorem from the usual axioms
and if we run the proof of the defined
geometric proof
in this case we get a proof of 17 steps
which is essentially a proof of daily's
theorem
it's not completely general because we
have one of the angles
but it could it would work with any
other angle and you see at the bottom
here it does a little algebra
um to find that that angle is
one half pi d and this is what the proof
graph looks like we'll get in detail
into another proof graph
but it shows the connections between the
the givens and
which are these three and how it goes
through the reasoning
to find the end
the desired theorem now there's another
possible uses that you may have noticed
in the second slide
you can ask it to prove all consequences
and this can uh if you might have you
might know this can
possibly bog the prover down but in
smaller
scenes it tends to work very well and
gives you
everything you'd like to know so for
example
in this diagram we have three parallel
lines
and one line that cuts transversely
across them at an angle of 30 degrees so
here's a diagram
and if we find all the things it could
prove in that diagram
basically it shows us
that basically it shows us that it gives
us all six
angles so uh three of 30 degrees and
three a 150 degrees
you might be thinking well there's
actually 12 angles but
angles on the other side see these
angles
are not shown because we're only told
about these
line segments and there's no way to name
this other angle because there's no
point out here
so now let's actually play with the
proof graph
the proof graph has a lot of interesting
uh options you can do
the if you hover over the edges it will
show you the proof that is involved you
can
click on the edges if you hover over the
vertices it shows you the fact
and you can label them
you can uh be stretched out a bit
you can label them you can put indices
on them and
that kind of thing um
if we talk about proving all theorems we
can
give a rough estimate of how many
how many theorems we can come up with at
each step if we iterate
on geometric proof the way we do that is
to realize that
there's about 30 background theorems and
each of the theorems typically takes
about
three inputs some take two as you can
see
most of them in this case take two
but on that some of them take more than
on average they take three
so we have to apply all these 30
theorems
and each one is about n choose three
different ways we could try to apply it
and then of those attempts of those 30
times
unchoose three attempts let's say 25 of
them actually result
in a new theorem so we have this
recurrence relation we solve it
and you see we get a double exponential
function so
there's really a cliff that we drop off
at some point that
where the prover does from where the
proverb does very nicely to where it
really bogs down
um if the proofer is unable to find a
proof
then it'll return a failure object so in
this case we have a nice scene
where we're given some lengths we're
given a to p
we're doing the a we're getting b to p
and we're given eight it uh that's it
and for if we ask it to use that
use that geometric scene here the same
scene
um to find the length from b to c well
it can't do it because
um as you can maybe think about there's
not enough relevant information to find
that
distance so it gives an error message
and returns this failure object
but there's still a lot of information
that you might want in the failure
object
there's a partial proof object or a
proof object that is a partial proof
so it doesn't uh all go down to one
sort of like uh proving all things it
doesn't necessarily
end in the one thing that you wanted but
it is a proof of everything it could
brew
before it either timed out or did too
many iterations or
it found that it couldn't prove anymore
and there's also an
augmented scene property which basically
puts back
the things that could prove in the scene
itself so in this case one thing we
could prove
is that the area bpo is 4 times the
square root of 65.
so if we draw that augmented scene
we see that we have a little triangle
there
as well because we know the area
now if a scene results in a
contradiction
and it's found by the prover it will
return a proof of that contradiction and
just like in the case
which i forgot to mention that you
actually prove your specific fact
in both these cases it will prune the
proof that is it will cut away
everything that was proved that wasn't
necessary for the curve
so here we have um we're given a couple
angles
and some some parallel lines on a
parallelogram essentially and we're
given two angles of the parallelogram
that don't match they should add to 180
and they don't and here's the the proof
of the contradiction here
now finally we can even add
geometric units measurements in angles
and lengths
and even in our effect pattern so here
we have a triangle similar to the
preliminary example
except in this case the one of the
distances is given in meters
another one is given in inches squared
and in this case we can even ask for
a quantity in meters or kilometers
for the for the base y the distance from
y to z
and we get a proof object and we can
check the result
property and the result tells us in
meters how many uh
what is the distance even though it
wasn't the one of the other ones was in
some other
unit so here we have the proof graph
here
very similar to the first one again
thank you very much hi my name is
stefania and i am
the geometry developer of oprah nothing
today i'm going to give a short overview
of
energy value and compute video clip
so we have been continually adding
scenes from classical geometry to the
warframe knowledge base
as for now we have 341 since curated
each thing is represented as an entity
and you can obtain the full list through
this entity value function here
and this list it's just a part of it
and the properties can be obtained
through entity value or using
entity properties and here is the list
of all the properties and
we're going to demonstrate it with
a random entity so
you can obtain a random sample of entity
using random entity or through entity
value
and we're looking at euclid book one
proposition 36
here the most important properties are
the statement and the same
so the statement um states that
what the theorem is actually about and
saying
it's what we curated the theorem
in warfarin language and you can also
put
the geometric scene into random instance
so that it gives out a
diagram of this theorem
so the list of named entity classes can
be obtained through energy value or
using entity class list
so each scene it's
put into one or more of the classes
and here is the list of all the classes
and to obtain a list of things
from a specific class you can use this
function here
anti-value entity class
so here is the sample of all the things
from the circle class
and now i'm moving on to the structure
of euclid's element
it is located in the data repository
it contains all the textual information
of definitions combinations postulates
and theorems
from euclid's elements
so you can retrieve the data using this
resource
object structure of euclid segment
and for retrieving the data for a
specific
entry you can put the
entry name at the end of this resource
data structure of equals element
and here are all the information
so the list of properties of each entree
can be found here it has the
greek and english text for the statement
and for the proofs and
there is also a list of the reference
that
theorems that got referenced in the
proofs
so you can retrieve this for example
reference
here
and about the axioms so
it is the postulates and common notions
from
euclid book one so there are 10 of them
and you can also find the theorems or
definitions
from a specific book
so here are some simple analysis
examples um we have
all the information from euclid book 1
through 13
and have all the definitions and
theorems for them
and this graph it's
the uh like how many
uh theorems that got referenced for
every proof and you can also find
the most popular theorems
and now we're going to have a preview of
the computable euclid
side it is still under development and
it's not live yet it is
constructed using our firm language
and to show how we can make euclid
computable
so here is the front page that we have
those
tiles of categories
and as for now we only have your
clipbook 1 through
6 and book 13
but we're adding more things to it
and through one of those tiles you can
go to the
category page slash class page
so here is the sample class page for
euclid book one
here we have a short paragraph of
the content of book one and then
we have those propositions listing
and this is not a complete list
and through one of the propositions you
can click and go to the next
theorem page here we're showing the uh
euclid book one proposition 47
and we have all the statement the same
the proof of this theorem
and we're also planning to add the
dependency graph to show like how
this theorem is related to other
propositions
in euclid
so yes please stay tuned for
the update of our computability clip
site and
i really hope that it could be a
valuable
asset to people that are interested in
euclid and to
students that are learning euclidean
geometry
thank you so much